i'm here with raf meersman the CEO of
comm saw at the ftth event in london raf
you gave us an interesting insight last
year about the deployment cost of FTTH
and you've honed that right down now
into the german market what are some of
the main findings that you've announced
today yes so I think the main conclusion
of the study we did now was that we
first of all confirmed the number on the
eu-27 level by refining the numbers for
the German market that means well our
numbers are optimized and pretty pretty
challenging but we confirmed that also
in the German market deployment is
possible for a tight budget we also
clearly show the challenges that also
need to be tackled for that mainly one
of the main challenges in the German
market is I think also the drenching the
way of doing trenching because there are
big labor costs within Germany so you
have to control them and you have to try
to manage them in the best possible way
by using the best possible new
technologies that are available and that
was one of the key findings I think of
this study yeah were there any other
lessons for the country is looking to
emulate with the ftth well I think one
of the lessons for for other countries
as well is that it's not necessarily or
it's not impossible to also deploy fiber
to the whole country including also more
rural parts if you use the right
technologies and the right involvement
of people so we we always look at a full
deployment not not just focusing on the
big cities and even then costs are under
control so that that's definitely
important and also on the like I said
before the new technologies and the new
things which are happening which allow
to decrease the costs and deploy as
efficient as possible is definitely
showing in the results that there is a
lot of potential there to also stimulate
the deployments in the whole of Europe
include
rural developments yeah now I know it
comes off you guys are pretty much
experts in this field how do you go
about you're making your calculations
what's the system you use how do you do
it basically yeah I think we're have a
quite a unique approach because what
what we do is with our own software we
we look at a large set of areas in
detailed with detailed GIS data which
shows the whole region including the the
locations of homes and streets and we do
a full calculation of a real Network on
such a large areas in total for Germany
we calculated 2.3 million of homes where
we did a real Network calculation and
this is quite unique because those are
real plans of a network that can be
constructed like that so the reliability
of the numbers is very high because
they're based on this kind of large real
calculations and also on the
extrapolation we we are quite unique in
the sense that we also look at populated
areas so we try to exclude areas like
forest and agricultural areas from the
extrapolation model because of course
there you don't have to go with your
fiber and if you take that into account
you overestimate often the costs because
that's just area you don't need to cover
with your fiber so it so it's very very
accurate basically that now I think
you're planning a possible webinar with
the ftth council about this whole this
whole area yes that's right we have a
lot of details we want to share we want
to be very open on this model just
because to prove the value when the
quality of this model but of course here
in the slot there is not a lot of time
so we are planning to do a detailed
webinar as soon I think it's somewhere
in April probably why we have more time
to explain all the details and to have
also open up the discussion with anyone
who wants to do to comment on our
methodology and assumptions okay raffle
thanks for sharing the news with us
today my pleasure thank you so that was
rough reporting latest figures for
Germany from the ftth Council and a
webinar coming up fairly soon
you